[Music]
all right we're doing telling a little
different on the Rubin report today for
the past two years we've sat down one on
one to interview interesting relevant
people finding out what they think and
why they think it every week I also try
to share with you what's on my mind with
an explanation as to why discussing the
ideas of the week is so important one of
the things that we promised you when we
launched on patreon last year was that
when we hit the 30k a month mark we'd
start expanding the show in new ways
such as hosting debates and doing more
live streams well just last week we did
three live streams with Carl Benjamin
aka sargon of akkad Tim pool and Maajid
Nawaz this week we're going to host our
first debate we aren't quite at that 30k
mark yet but we wanted to offer this up
as a tease of what's to come and show
you that our commitment to bringing you
new engaging content is as strong as
ever so joining me today are two former
guests of the Rubin report and more
importantly two people that I'm proud to
call my friend Dennis Prager is a
conservative radio host and author of
several best-selling books Michael
Shermer is the founding publisher of
skeptic magazine and also the author of
several best-selling books I find both
of them to be engaging interesting and
unafraid to share their personal and
political views about three months ago
Dennis did a video for his YouTube
channel Prager you in which he made the
case that without God there is no
objective truth to tell us murder isn't
wrong a few days later Michael made a
follow-up video on why he believes that
you can indeed have morality without God
Michael's response to Dennis was
respectful and thoughtful and I thought
that it opened a door for us to have a
conversation about one of the most
fundamental issues about what it means
to be human and to live a good life so
without further ado I present you our
first Reuben report conversation not
debate but conversation with two guests
who hold deeply held opposing beliefs
but who I know will be honest decent and
respectful at the same time here we go
[Music]
all right guys I'm thrilled to be doing
this today because I am sitting here
between two men that I totally respect
but more importantly I consider friends
that I have broken bread with that I
have just spent time in the green room
chatting with so first let's do some
intro is here is Dennis Prager to my
right Michael Shermer to my left and
we're going to do something a little
different today a little different than
I normally do I've had both of you on
the show before we've talked about your
ideas and let you say what you think
about things and today we're going to
have a discussion on something that you
guys feel very differently about but I
think can do it in a respectful honest
and decent way we're going to be talking
about morality and God something that
both of you have written a lot about you
did a Prager you do about three months
ago and that's what sort of kicked off
the idea for this conversation and
before we do anything even even about
the video and even putting morality and
God aside for a second I thought we
should start first by just three people
sitting in a room that are okay
disagreeing on some stuff it has become
incredibly rare the idea that you guys
have a totally different view on
something that's really one of the most
existential questions that there is but
we were all just hanging out out there
and your wife's here and my parents are
out there and we were all everyone was
chatting and laughing have a good time
and this has become almost an endangered
species of an idea
so let's just start there why do you
think this has happened I know the
reason but I'm afraid to say it because
it's it will sound like I'm just a
political advocate but I have no choice
I believe that it is virtually entirely
a product of the left and Mike I could
prove it I truly believe it's provable I
have I have an acronym six herb sexist
intolerant xenophobic homophobic
Islamophobic racist bigoted if you
differ with anyone from the New York
Times I'm not talking about crackpot
left normal
if you differ with them you are bad
you're not wrong you are bad and that's
that's the origin we don't have that we
do not have a sick Serb conservatives
don't have a list of adjectives that are
comparable and and and that's why I
attribute it to the left
see how he buttered me up to start my
own right going right to my wheelhouse
now Dennis continues himself a
conservative you're sort of a
libertarian if we had to give you a
label that we labels are always
problematic today I'll have in their
mind what they think that is like Oh Ron
Paul no wait a minute I don't agree with
everything with classical liberal I like
and I was glad to see you you know kind
of throw that back into the ring is
that's a label that's we should all be
using I like that yeah but what what do
you think has happened to conversation I
know both of you guys by the way you do
actually do this you debate people in a
respectful way I'm considering this more
of a conversation and a debater I'm not
scoring this thing at the end right now
Leroy I'm not announcing a winner but
what do you think has happened to that
because even debates these days with
with people that are pretty well known
and and you know big authors and things
have sort of devolved into I think what
Dennis is talking about we're percenter
what do they have it well I think I
think in part I think dennis is put is
largely correct it's more from the left
and the right certainly and in the
Academy I think it evolved from the 60s
emphasis on the use of language and how
certain words are toxic and caused
people to think differently and so you
start for something like the n-word
let's stop using that okay and things
like use his-and-her rather than always
his all right you know these are small
things but maybe that you know okay so
they kind of get you to comment kind of
go along with some of that you know like
I've wrote about Sam bozos you know how
they look like Sam bows they have the
images of the little black kid is like
okay that's no longer cool and we've all
kind of made that transition and most of
its reasonable but then you start you
know cascading along the spectrum to
like every word you say every phrase the
way you turn it microaggressions you
know there's no evidence at all that
microaggressions cause harm there's not
been a single study by a theological
I think they're not been studies saying
that it doesn't actually I think I don't
even came out this week but that's right
yeah yeah so so it just kind of caught
on as an idea that's kind of a political
movement idea that then got absorbed by
the left so the left argument is that
okay so words matter words can hurt then
all of a sudden words are violence and
therefore it's okay to commit violence
against somebody who uses words wait a
minute when did that happen
right and this is this concept of
punching Nazis which I've been saying
you cannot punch the run right over an
idea okay so so one other thing before
we get into the meat of this but the
crux of this is is basically that you
are a believer and that you are not a
believer so well that's not the crooks
forgive me
but I take it away though III don't
think it is because I have debated
atheists like at Oxford many years ago
and it's in print and it's on the
internet so one could see it the
professor Jonathan Jonathan Glover who's
an atheist and a professor moral I think
world philosophy then at Oxford now at
another British University the first
thing he said when we debated was I
agree with mr. Prager if there is no God
ethics are subjective so and there are
people who believe in God who agree with
Michael that it's whether or not there's
a God is is is important obviously but
still ethics are subjective no matter
what or you can have objective ethics
without God so the fact that he's not a
believer in I am a believer is not fully
dispositive okay that that's a fair
critique and you actually mention that
in your in your video that you get up on
paper you that's wrong as you say that
exact thing so okay I'll rephrase it a
little bit and just say you are a
believer and you are not a believer fair
right or fair okay correct so then I
just want to ask one other thing and
then we're going to jump in were you
always a believer and where does that
come from within you
well I I was all I was raised in a
religious Jewish home an Orthodox Jewish
home I I didn't stay Orthodox but I
stayed religious but ironically and I do
write about this elsewhere you could
again on the Internet
how I found God at Columbia the truth is
is the the this is will sound odd but
the biggest single factor in moving me
to believe in God has been the secular
foolishness that has permeated our
society I was taught at Columbia's a
prestigious place by very bright secular
often non-believers and I was taught
mostly nonsense and I remember I went
crazy thinking why is there so much
nonsense being taught at an Ivy League
university by bright people then a
phrase from the Bible came into my brain
in Hebrew and it's very well known to
people who've studied the Bible you will
know the phrase certainly and that is
wisdom begins with fear of God and then
I realized Wow
no God no wisdom and that has that has
permit permeated my life in other words
it is the the anti God crowd that has
made me realize how important God is
that's it's not God didn't appear to me
the religious have not convinced me it
be irreligious have convinced me of the
centrality of God to the world for that
everything you didn't have the burning
bush my hell no I have the opposite I
had a frozen bush yeah yes yes I
actually mentioned on a few weeks ago on
the show I did hike Mount Sinai myself
and I was ready I mean I was about 21
and I was ready to see a burning bush
and I hiked at the wrong time of day so
I was you know dripping with sweat and I
had eaten some bad pigeon in Egypt so I
was having some stomach problems on the
holiest mountain out of my feet and and
nothing nothing happened when I got up
there and I really was ready so for you
I mean I know this so I'm leaving a
little bit but were you always a
non-believer where did this come yes I
was raised in a largely secular home my
parents were not religious neither were
they anti religious for atheists or it
just never came up and you know when I
was around in the 50s and 60s that
wasn't a thing like you know what you're
religious are you an atheist you know
atheism wasn't even a
really to be so but when I went to high
school and then in college you know the
born-again movement was kind of taking
off so I became a born-again in high
school in 1971 I went to Pepperdine
University with the Church of Christ
school
very conservative at the time and and I
was pretty serious about it I mean I
took all the Bible classes the Old
Testament the New Testament the life of
Christ the writings of CS Lewis I've
read everything user either it written
and so forth and then and I in what
door-to-door because if you're an
evangelical by definition you're
supposed to evangelize that's what you
do so you know Amway with Bibles yeah I
did it and and I like doing it and and
then when I became when I kind of gave
that up I wasn't really a militant
atheist because again that wasn't really
a thing in the late 70s and early 80s
when I sort of dropped my religious
beliefs and you know and said that
brings us to this point that a theism
isn't really a thing to be it's just a
lack of belief
full-stop so what do you believe you
know science and reason and civil
liberties and civil rights and equal
treatment and all these kind of is
lightin that values that we might call
enlightenment humanism or whatever
classical liberalism you know those are
the things I believe in I don't believe
in atheism because it isn't a worldview
it's just sure I don't believe it God .
now what so then it becomes okay so are
those values that you believe in equal
treatment under the law of women's
rights gay rights civil liberties right
and wrong you know is killing right his
murder wrongs it yes I believe they're
real and you believe they're real so the
question then is well what's the source
right and that basically brings us to
you for them and I are doing this video
yes I have a question for you and then
it's not a trick or Nothing I'm very
curious
it's and I say oh and you you know I
think you've heard my show on a few
occasions and I so we're gonna get down
here yes absolutely yourself no no III
why not I mean it you know why not
listen to me why not have you on my show
okay
so I say I now say I've written on this
the life like the question I most want
an answer to most curious to get events
do from an atheist do you hope you're
right or do you hope you're wrong
I don't really hope I just sort of go
along and just try to lead a good life
and I'm not hoping for anything really I
mean if it turned out there's a god yes
would you be would you be happy I mean
are there look there are undoubtedly
people you love in your life so if there
is a God and the traditional belief is
an afterlife you would have you would
reconnect sure and I we had I would be
glad about what works okay that's all
okay let me tell why I had yes that
would be the reason if that was the
version that was real you know to mean
people well if God is good there's an
afterlife if God is an idiot or God is
cool or God doesn't give a damn about
his creation then there's no afterlife
but on the I make only two leaps of
faith it's all I make that that God
exists that God as the creator and God
is good and if if that's the case then
there's an afterlife that's all you
can't have a good God and this totally
unjust world be the only existence that
that would be a cruel God that's all but
I learnt in depth and the only reason by
the way I asked it is because and I'm
happy you did that because I respect you
as you know and and I am always puzzled
if an atheist doesn't answer well of
course it would be nice or of course I'd
like it it doesn't it doesn't undermine
your position in the least I think it
gives you credibility that in other
words against your your desire
nevertheless your mind has reasoned out
there is no God which is why isn't that
completely consistent though with the
things you believe yeah sort of that you
have a curious mind so have you found
out at the end that it was a little
different than perhaps you thought I
would be curious to know how was it done
you know it did and what is it that
actually happens in the subject of my
next book heavens on earth that you know
so I talked about the idea of uploading
the mind into a computer you know
copying all your memories you get to
live forever or it how is that different
really from God pulling you up out of
the grave what's he pulling up because
most religions believe you know the body
stays in the grave and the soul or the
copy of you goes to heaven well if it's
a copy of me then it's not really me and
so what's actually going on there I'd be
curious to know how that works
if that's the case and also I do have
some issues about heaven though I mean
is
boring I mean the turn journey is a long
time especially near the end is you know
and and you know as hitch famously said
heaven would be like celestial North
Korea I don't want a dictator that knows
every one of my thoughts so this can't
be I'm thinking of it as a human that
can't be what heaven would be like but I
don't actually even know Dennis what
what we're talking right I don't either
I only know that a good God has figures
out how to undo the terrible injustice
of this life that's it I'm curious I
wasn't planning on even asking this but
would you both concede that the other
one could be right of course he could be
right obviously I would only say I
intellectually this has obviously
Melanie with Michael who I have great
respect for intellectually I respect
agnosticism more than atheism the the
certitude that that implies
I don't intellectually quite understand
it's like I don't understand a believer
who never has doubts I don't get it so I
don't understand an atheist who never
has doubt that's a fair critique because
we hear that a lot of these days I think
we hear it more unusual - clarification
on the terms yeah agnostic technically
when Huxley coined the term he meant
unknowable not like you're waiting there
for one more experiment or one more
piece of data and then I'll make up my
mind it's just not knowable in any you
know rational scientific sense and I and
so on to logically speaking I'm an
agnostic
we can't know there's no experiment
we're going to run it there it is you
know point oh five levels significance
God exists right atheist so there's
strong and weak atheism so starting
atheism I know there's no God that to me
is an indefensible position so we can
see ISM I just don't believe in a God it
could be wrong you know that that's the
more defensible position yeah that would
be my position and I think that's sort
of consistent yes yeah well more so
obviously the earth I I mean this is not
obviously the subject but it doesn't
matter it's a greatest I like anyway I
intellectually not emotionally not
religiously I don't get how someone can
look at the universe and think it came
about on its own
I debated the Lawrence Krauss on the
show so you know who said something from
nothing
yeah so what a given positive faith I
said so what is nothing they said well
nothing is something and I have you know
how respectfully I treat people I differ
with because because you've been on the
show a number of times yeah and I was
respectful but I did say something to
the effect ah you know I'm now entering
a sort of voodoo land if some if nothing
is something then nothing isn't nothing
you can't have it both ways
couldn't you uphold some sort of
rabbinical something out I probably
could if I really yes if it turns on how
what we mean by these words you know so
when a physicist like Lawrence Krauss
talks about nothing he doesn't mean it
in the same way a theologian might say
nothing because there is no nothing in
physics there's always some energy field
a quantum foam field something like this
that things pop out of like photons of
light don't exist and they pop out of
nothing in atoms so this art there's
already happened something comes from
nothing that all physicists agree oh
that's how like is formed ok so why
can't a university this is Lawrence's
argument so when he says nothing he
means you know something different and I
think at some point we kind of hit an
epistemological wall when we talk about
things like nothing eternity
you know infinity you know we as finite
beings that are in a three-dimensional
world four dimensional we can't really
know what those words mean on some say
they cause make sense yeah something
outside of us do you think that could be
just the great existential question of
being a human that we simply you know
we're going to do it we'll do this we
can go for hours if you want if we can
have you guys clear out your evenings do
dinner here - but we're you know to me
like a certain amount there's a certain
amount of people in between right that
may go you know cragars making a little
sense and it'll move me that way or sure
is mingling to move me that way but that
most people at a certain point in life
you can't get them to move too far
right that's why I just I fully admit I
don't
I don't quite understand seeing the
universe and concluding that on rational
grounds just rational logical grounds
this all came from nothing and that all
the design I see implies no designer I
debated the head of American Atheists
they were wonderful group by the way
they and I always say they gave me the
check that day a lot of religious crap
so I just want to be clear we're
disabled children I don't recall the
name of I feel bad but they had their
annual convention in Minneapolis and I
debated their head and I looked at the
audience at one point and just it just
struck me to ask them I it was very
spontaneous I said how many of you
please raise your hand if you have ever
doubted your atheism and now one hand
went up so they maybe were afraid to
raise their hand activity like well all
right that's partying which is an
interesting point action but but I made
the point I said look when a child is
born with terrible deformity every
believer I know goes where's God we
answer but so when a child is born
perfectly formed why doesn't the atheist
go wow that's that's death it doesn't
seem that it's completely random
well not random it's still a WoW moment
for all of us well no wow but it's a
random well not random yeah so it says
well it's either zuzo and/or red no no
so the forces of nature are non-random
that you know the the emergent property
of complexity comes from simplicity by
the laws of nature themselves it's built
into the system now you can ask what
were the laws of matrix yes well I would
ask you where's Scott you still have the
same problem with the infinite regress
argument that if you say well God did it
well where did God come from well God is
that which does not need to be created
well why can't the University that which
does not because the universe is
physical and God is better well there
could be a pre-existing state you know
again we you know we can only push back
so far to the you know the way you could
only push back so far within the
physical universe
that's what but the eye
that's something outside of the physical
realm made the physical realm is more
coherent to me than the physical realm
made itself well but but there could be
multiple universes okay that's it later
okay now I that's where you lose me well
so that I don't you know the Dave Rubin
show is happening just like this because
there's an infinite number you're not
that kind of octuple universe not a
letter show than this that's often got
ripped open but so that argument you
that's the same thing as the Kraus
argument right like you mean a multiple
universe yes the mobile year it's a
cop-out no no no no there's a he knows
better than I because he knows more
science than I you cannot possibly ever
there will not not possible for us to it
it kept contact or proved another
universe be so it's it's ace it's a
statement made that has less argument
for it than the belief in God yeah well
I don't think he said it was provable I
know he didn't say it but but even
offering it as an argument
if that's your if that's your argument
then I have a good sound argument okay
it's not quite the argument so first of
all dispense with the multiple universes
where we're sitting here in another
studio some you know I don't go for that
okay but there but the idea that there
could be an eternal sequence or cycles
of universes you know kind of a Buddhist
sort of thing or in do sort of thing or
all the way up to us you know there's a
half a dozen of these physical theories
that are put forth by businesses they're
not met they're not like oh I'm an
atheist I got to come up with something
that's not what they're doing they're
making predictions based on the
mathematical principles of the universe
and how these laws of nature's could
come about and so on they may all be
wrong they may never even be tested we
don't know and that's perfectly OK in
science to throw those kinds of things
out there and see what happens maybe the
gravitational wave research now that's
all the things that that may be able to
detect colliding universes from you know
that cause these gravity waves to treat
something like that as possible but now
but that could make it testable at the
moment is not testable so both of us end
up at an epistemological wall where we
can't go any further and then that we're
just using words well God is that which
does not need to be created as outside
of space and time ok these are just
words were using we don't know that no I
don't know that I
it makes more sense than the physical
world and everything in it you and I
both love music you know so there is no
appoint Bach who I'm sure you adore a
box entually the father of Western clubs
may be the best argument for God's
existence by the way is Bobby yes that's
why I'm using that hand and I think
matter playing the violin right and he
wrote on every one of his manuscripts
for the greater glory of God so you hear
this stuff and and you so we've gone
from photons to buff and and that's
designed but there's no designer why
that strikes you is more logical is my
puzzle well okay so the derivative of
complex ideas from simpler ideas and
from big brains from smaller brains you
can see the gradation and evolution so
the chip can't do Buck the dog can't do
Bach or morality for that matter so the
reason we're different than say lions
killing something and why we would call
it murder in the lion would is because
we have brains big enough capable of
conceiving of morality
music mathematics logic poetry and so on
and that is special
wherever sources it's we all recognize
it as being transcendently special
[Music]
you